confirmed at 6:08 p.m. Central time I
rode back from space this time on a
Soyuz the Russian spaceship it's an
extremely efficient surgical brutal way
to come home
you come down and ya thump back to earth
and your body has to instantaneously go
from the graceful elegance of Perpetual
weightlessness to the to the tyranny of
gravity it's rude when you get home I
mean your body is so confused and and
your balance system is messed up and you
don't have proper blood pressure
regulation you're nauseous you can't
walk you can't balance it's as if you've
just got off this horrible spinning ride
coupled with the worst flu you have ever
had it's just it's a nasty day or two
after about two weeks they'll let you
drive again you know so that you're safe
with a car but it took about four months
before I could run again because the the
pounding of the feet on the pavement you
think about throwing your legs down at
the pavement with each stride it's sort
of like dropping your blood hard down
towards the ground in here so your heart
has to work doubly hard to lift it back
up to your head
everybody wants to know what's it like
in space what is it like what do you how
do you trim your mustache how do you
brush your teeth how do you go to the
bathroom I need to do all these things
and so I kind of resolve to myself that
if I get up there long enough I'm gonna
try and make a quick video and show
those things and anything else that I
think is sort of cool and one of the
first things I was doing I got up there
and I'd been in quarantine for a while
and my fingernails were a little bit
long and I thought I'm gonna trim my
fingernails and just before I started
doing it I thought hmm this is different
than on earth maybe I'll just make a
quick video about it why not and so I
just stuck up a camera and did a little
intro and move the camera and millions
of people watched it so my guess was
true that people did just have a
fundamental curiosity and the more we
made the more people watched him and
some of them just went crazy something
as simple as a national science
experiment of what happens when you
wring out a cloth in space to me it was
obvious what was gonna happen but it was
so visually surprising to everybody what
the water did when you run out of cloth
that I mean 9 or 10 million people out
of it people stopped me in the street
and go hey that thing you did was cool
made me think about it and the beauty of
it is not only was it cool but it made
people think
but playing that guitar is weird in
space because he does this thing up in
echo - to ten ten ten ten
when your arm comes our hand comes up
the neck because the guitar is actually
just floating in front of you as your
hand comes up the whole guitar it takes
off sideways so you have to find some
new way to brace the guitar or or hold
it or velcro it to you or something it's
it's you have to relearn how to play
guitar
the space station is a hugely active
laboratory I mean it's just it's just a
big busy thriving place and we're
somewhere between lab technicians and
lab rats the whole time it has about 200
experiments going simultaneously all the
time so that that's a busy lab if you
look at any lab on earth some of them
are really hands-on like the flame
experiments or the cardiac ultrasounds
we do one of the best experiments on the
space station is the Alpha Magnetic
Spectrometer which is gathering
subatomic particles and whatever the
universe throws at us in this huge
magnet with a great number of layers of
arrays of detectors to try and figure
out what the universe is made of
Mars is further than almost everybody
thinks it's gonna take half a year just
to get there that you're gonna leave
earth and not get somewhere for a long
long time so the psychological impact of
that is going to be that there's nothing
in your window there's no huge
stimulating omnipresence of view of our
planet the whole time to look at
whenever you're not doing something else
and those crews on the way to Mars are
going to have a schism with the earth
within a week or two I think because the
earth is now a distant visual memory and
communications are going to get slow
enough that you can no longer have a
real-time talk with anybody and that
crew are gonna become Martians within a
few weeks I think they have to for their
own psychological health they will have
to no longer be from Earth and they will
have started viewing themselves as being
from somewhere else